but it's Mike from order flows and
welcome to this presentation on the
order flows bulge which is an indicator
that runs on ninjatrader 8 now before I
begin you know a brief disclaimer be
aware that there is risks involved in
trading and don't trade with money you
can't afford to lose now one of the
things that I truly love about trading
is that opportunities are always
presenting themselves if you know how to
recognize them and order flow allows us
to look inside the chart see the actual
buying and selling between market
participants know the information
available to traders today versus 25
years ago is amazing but at the same
time overwhelming and give you an
example this is a chart there's a CQG
chart from 1995 yeah some people still
use charts that just look like this but
now we have order flow chart which you
know break down the volume traded on the
bid the volume traded on the offer so
you can see where the aggressive buying
and selling is occurring and at what
price and basically it gives you so much
more information over a normal
candlestick chart I don't know why
people still use candlestick charts I
find that once people start using order
flows charts you know they they don't go
back to simple candlestick charts unless
they're running order flows based
indicators on those charts you know and
in the last 25 years we've seen a
quantum shift in information available
to the trader so let me ask you you know
are you still stuck in 1995 are you
still stuck using this type of chart
okay fine I would talk about the order
flows Balt which is a tool that you can
put on your simple candlestick chart
that was gonna analyze the order flow
for you you know and the best way to
describe it is which would you rather
use now you know the old Nokia phone or
you're gonna use an iPhone you know 99%
of the traders out there will use an
iPhone as opposed to a Nokia phone the
events is an order flow now give the
trader the chance to determine if market
activity is normal light or heavy and
this is seen through the volume in order
flow now you know I've been in the
trading business so to speak you know I
started on the CMA floor in 94 and I've
worked for many of the top trading
companies in the world JP Morgan Cargill
Commerce Bank you know to name a few
and you know it back in the old days
this is back in the 90s this is what an
order book depth of market look like
this was time and sales this was the
ticker now you have these beautiful
charts this is from my software the
order flows trader which basically takes
all this information and puts it into an
easy-to-read format so that you can make
a better trading decision but when I was
looking at these charts what was I
really looking at I was looking at
market activity and participation
you know when market activity is normal
the market is doing what it's supposed
to do its facilitating trade it's
transferring risk from one party to
another in an orderly fashion with
minimal price fluctuation something a
drink there when market activity has a
lot of traders aren't interested in
taking a position one way or another the
market lacks participation and will
often lack movement so you know when
people aren't interested in trading the
markets not gonna go anywhere it's just
gonna sit still
now when market activity is heavy it's a
sign of big traders coming into the
market and the big traders are the
institutions who are often involved you
know markets supply chain and have the
power to move the market you know
institutions is a term that gets thrown
out a lot by people that make videos
that make indicators and it generally
means banks commercials producers hedge
funds and sovereign wealth funds so you
know when I talk about institutions you
know basically I talked about what I
mean is the big traders but there is a
difference even among these institutions
on the ways that they've traded now I've
traded for banks I've traded for a
commercial trading company so I know the
difference and I've had friends that
work at all these types of companies as
well and I understand how they trade now
I've had the good fortune to work at two
of the largest investment banks in the
world JP Morgan for eight years and
Commerce Bank for three years as well as
two of the largest commodity trading
firms in the world Cargill for four
years ETF man for two years if you're
unfamiliar with these companies you look
him up on Google you'll be shocked about
the if you never heard a Cargill how big
it is as a trading company it's a
privately held company but they come for
about 30% of the United States grain
exports 20% of the meat exports there
so involved in shipping you know energy
markets as well as they're just massive
so when I talk about what institutions
do in the market it comes from my own
first-hand real-world trading experience
that I did during my professional
trading career you know over the years
I've explained to traders how to use
Oracle Otzi when institutional traders
are buying or selling in the market you
know if you're looking at a normal bar
chart forget that you can't see volume
traded on the bid at offer if you're
looking at a normal bar chart forget it
you know you can't see volume traded on
the bid or offer at a price now before
the footprint chart I stared at a dome
right the depth of market and a time in
sales log that's where I learned how to
read order flow you know this is what a
normal candlestick chart looks like you
know people are gonna come up with all
sorts of fancy lines drawn on here and
moving averages to predict this move but
you know what if you're looking at order
flow sometimes it can be very clear on
what's about to happen you know when I
was introduced to the footprint chart it
was like discovering a whole new world I
was able to see in here right this this
is this area right up in here right
before the big market meltdown here
Thursday you know I could see up here
that there's resistance selling you know
this is what I call a primary point of
control
that's why that this point of control
instead of being drawn
you know gray is this magenta that's a
very bearish sign for me in the order
flow now with order flow right there was
a way that I could organize the market
generated data into a format that's much
easier to read you know I started
transferring my trading style over from
reading a dome and time and sales into
what I was seen on a footprint you know
was essentially doing by mental
calculation and relying on memory let's
now revealed right in front of me plus I
could have the computer do the analysis
for me you know some of my
bread-and-butter trades already if you
watch a lot of my videos right I talked
about this trade here this is the ratio
the bearish ratio they got my single
print up here it's very bearish sign you
know here I see you know the single
print it's coming right after you know
we're selling
we make this pullback up here you know
then it follows up with the negative
Delta's is also very bearish bearish
sign coming in right here after it looks
like this market is gonna make another
run up to this high take out the high if
you're reading the order flow you'd
understand what's going on in there now
another important trade setup that
explained was what I call the order
Falls bulbs which is what this
presentation is about and what I call
the Bulge is when there's larger than
normal buying or selling at a price in a
bar but you know just having larger than
normal volume at a price by itself has
no meaning you have to put it in context
of what's going on in the bar and in the
bars around it you know you see the bar
in the middle right you can see the
volume how it just gets bigger right 124
137 136 167 167 115 85 you know you see
these other bars around it you've got
very you know normal volumes basically
you know anywhere between 25 to 50 is
you know the volume is you're getting in
the other bars but here you're seeing
you know twice two two two times two
three times as much volume going through
so the order Falls bulge starts with the
larger the normal volume traded at a
price in a bar and looks at other
factors such as relative volume the
volume trade on the bid and the offer
volume traded on them you know where the
activity is occurring in the market
structure and much more you know when
the conditions are met in order flows
bulge is confirmed and it's signaled on
your chart this is what it looks like
here you could draw a zone out if you
like you can remove that zone and you
got your little up arrow for a buy you'd
have a down arrow for a sell this is a
sell right here you know this is a
five-minute chart and you see here this
is a 5000 volume chart but the beauty is
it will also work on a normal
candlestick chart
all right so if maybe you're not
interested in learning order flow you
just you know want to stick to your old
style of chart you could put this
indicator and it will run on it now
there's much a user-defined settings you
know you can determine in the Bulge
value you detect the Bulge anywhere you
can use a look-back filter to find
swings you know so if you want to find
swing highs or swing lows when these
bulges occur you can do that
you could use Delta confirmation meaning
that you know Delta has to be going in
the same direction as price action you
can use Delta divergence meaning price
action and Delta are different so
meaning you know price is going higher
but Delta is negative and you can use
prominent opponent controls right which
is what I showed you earlier when was
that chart right here now this is a
prominent point of control so if you
want to use that as a filter you know
saying you know the bar with the Bulge
has to have a prominent point of control
you can do that now what separates the
oracles balls from other order flow
based indicators is this new setting
that I put in it's called the trade
entry signal function and what the trade
entry signal is based on is how I trade
order flow now with order flow as with
any method of trading when you get into
a trade you need follow-through from
other traders what that means is you
know when you buy you need other traders
buying as well when you sell you need
other traders selling as well so if you
buy and all of a sudden sellers come
into the market your trades gonna become
a loser very quick you know if you sell
and all the Sun buyers are coming out of
nowhere you're gonna get stopped out
right because he's sold awesome but
people are buying markets going up you
know you're like I just sold you
know but everyone's buying you're gonna
get stopped out just as if you buy also
in a big seller comes in hits all the
bids
you're gonna stopped out you know you
don't want to be taking those trades
where you know when you get long sellers
are appearing or you get short buyers
are coming in and what the trade entry
signal is going to do is it's gonna help
eliminate some of those trades you know
because the question is how do you see
follow-through buying or selling well
you look at the order flow you look at
the price action you know so what we
added to the order Falls bulge is the
trade entry signal which once an order
Falls bolt
appears instead of signaling a trade
unless the order for confirm that a move
in the direction of the signals
happening then a buy or sell trade
signal is generated for example okay
this is the ball just to the Nasdaq is a
1-minute chart right you can see some
nice trades here right this nice sell
you know that's nice buy here you know
little bi here that's just sort of went
sideways for the cash open and cash open
boom big jump up there 20-point move 30
point move you know I thought hi got a
sell signal at the little you know swing
low here you gotta buy but there's just
losing trade here okay now sometimes you
get a signal you get short then what
happens you're short on here market
rallies right back so what we have this
function in here it's called the trade
entry signal you can either enable it or
disable it enable it you'd have to click
the button or you know click put a check
mark in there you just click on it and
it will fill it in then you're gonna
choose the trade price level in ticks
trade validity in bars so what that
means is you know over the next bars bar
or bars trade validity and bars you
gotta choose over how many bars you want
it to analyze what it means is the
market has to start moving in that
direction so if you're getting short
like on this losing trade right here in
the middle right for a sell signal to be
generated we gotta start trading lower
right if you're not gonna take out the
low of this bar you know over the next
several bars it's not gonna generate a
signal it's not going to generate a
trade signal right what you're seeing
here is just the basic signals okay with
this turned off the trade entry signal
turned off but when you turn it on this
is what it looks like it has still draws
the zone there you could remove this
zone if you like I like to keep it in
there you know sort of as was a warning
saying hey you know what we got
potential trade setting up because you
can see here right now you see the
signals coming in in the next bar right
in the next bar in two bars later two
bars later two bars later because I have
it set to two two so it's looking over
the next two bars and a price has to
start moving in that direction by at
least two ticks so you see in the next
bar it moved to by at least two ticks so
it's it's moving in that direction right
because oftentimes right you'll get into
a trade and the market will go sideways
and you'll just burn your emotional
capital so to speak you know wondering
all do I stay
trade do I get out you know you're
sitting in here sitting in here would
you rather give up a tick or two I mean
you said to one tick he says to tick the
max setting is 5 for both the price
levels and the validity I tend to keep
it at like 1 & 2 or 1 in 1 but again you
know you could do it up to 5 because you
know it's trades not gonna happen pretty
quick like over the next bar or two I'm
not really interested in it and so
instead of drawing the signal on the bar
were you know the Bulge is it draws the
signal in the bar afterwards or you know
in this case two bars afterwards when
the other conditions are met for getting
into the trade you know this is the
original setting without the trade entry
signal enabled you know for people that
trade on a dome you know that trade
either you know minute based charts they
tend to keep the trade entry signal
turned off because really they're
trading reversals is how they trade the
balls people that trade on don't you
know as soon as this appears you know
they're they're looking you know to buy
into a bar in here looking to get you
know take out a few ticks you know this
trade entry signal is more for people
that are gonna be buying it and holding
it for you know a period rather than
just you know try and scalping a few
ticks on the reversal so again you know
it's it's a new feature eventually it'll
roll out in all my other software's all
my other indicators but you don't find
it it's gonna keep you out of trades
like this it just goes sideways on you
you know if you sold here alright
because you got a sell signal you know
it's it's you know it's a legitimate
trade take but the price action of the
trade isn't going in that direction you
know you're not getting the
follow-through selling right it's like
think of it this way right you know I
see people you know comin to me oh you
know like I've figured out the markets
and you know they come up with this way
of finding market turning points okay
that nobody else knows about well I Got
News for you if nobody else knows the
markets gonna turn there except you
unless you're trading some big gigantic
massive size in the
get the mark is probably not gonna
reverse there it's just gonna be
coincidence that the market reversed at
that level so just like if you're
getting long alright what you want is
buyers coming in to the market also for
whatever reason you know and in this
case you know the order flow is telling
you you know earlier on there's there's
some you know buyers coming into this
market like on this bar here this big
bar your buyers were coming into the
market you know we saw oversized
activity coming in but the next bar it
wasn't that follow-through the next the
follow-through didn't come for another
bar later you know two bars the second
bar after the signal bar you know to
confirm that so yeah you know people
will say cuz with me the way I trade
order flow you know I let the bar close
before I get into a trade and I'm not
gonna get into a trade immediately after
the soon as the bar is closed I want the
bar to start the next bar to start
moving in that direction you know
instead of getting long as soon as this
bar closes and then you see you know
getting along at all for this market
sells down to you know ninety nine you
know I'm gonna wait for that market to
start moving in that direction I'm
willing to give up you know a few ticks
in some cases a few points span what
market I'm trading you know for that
confirmation because I don't want this
trade right here I don't want this type
of losing trade I want this trade you
know where the market just shoots right
up you know from I'm happy to instead of
getting long in the Nasdaq at Oh for
taking heat all the way down to 99 I'd
rather get in at oh eight and take it up
to twenty eight you know somewhere up in
here where I got this this the sell
signal catch this move I'm willing to
give up this because at the same time
I'm giving up this losing trade right
here all right imagine getting short
here at ninety four and you know where's
the best point the absolute best point
if you got short at ninety that's more
like ninety two and a half the best
point to get out would be here but
realistically you'd be getting out up
here at at you know at eight thousand
maybe even higher taking a full stop up
here you know at you know at O six you
know I don't want that I want this I
want this move you know I want more
potential
to the upside then a trade going
sideways and I got to sit here and hem
and haw I feel like I'm in a wrestling
match with the market do I get out you
know or not or what you know I don't
want that trade
I want this trade I want this trade I
want this trade I want this trade I want
this trade and that's what this trade
entry signal is for now some of you may
not want to use it that's fine you don't
have to you just don't enable it right
you can see now it's enable it's got the
little check mark there here doesn't
have the check mark so you know again
you know stop being confused whether
you're reading the order flow correctly
let the computer do it for you and now
let the computer tell you when to get
into the trade or not you know so you
know get the order flow bulge indicator
today you know I look forward to seeing
you on the inside so just go to order
flows calm slash bulge and you'll find
out more about the indicator I think
it's a fantastic indicator um you know I
release tools that are designed to help
traders understand the market read the
market and you know hopefully make a
profit from the market if they trade it
correctly now with this trade entry
signal it's gonna eliminate you getting
into these trades it's not gonna
generate a signal for you you know it'll
just say yep there's a bulge here but
you don't have the down down arrow here
telling you to get short here you have
the down arrow it's on you to get short
here you got the up arrow telling you
get long up arrow telling you to get
long down arrow telling you to get short
and when you see the down arrows or the
up arrows with the trade entry signal
enabled as soon as you see it that's
when you get into the trade you know if
you're using something like markers from
Pablo you know you can just run markers
with this when it generates the signal
so you have to worry about these trades
like this and taking a stop out you know
if you can eliminate imagine being able
to eliminate you know 25% 30% of trades
that don't work out you know that could
be the difference for some people from
having a profitable year or having a
losing here you know imagine you could
imagine you know you have five trades
and you take out you know the one trade
that was the loser
what's that worth you you know
ask yourself that so anyway I'll end
this video now and you know hope to see
you guys on the inside go to order Flo's
calm / bulge dot html' bye bye